well first and foremost such an honor to
get to chat with you i came and saw you
perform in toronto it was my last
concert ever before
this all happened and it's like one of
the best memories because i just like
danced my butt off and had the very best
time so it's so nice to connect with you
again charlie i am such a fan of good
ones congratulations on the new single
what would you say inspired both
musically and lyrically this single
because it is a very different vibe for
charlie xcx
yeah um
i'm glad you like it first of all and um
i mean it's interesting like even though
the past few years it's definitely been
you know about me kind of
playing with the more experimental side
of pop music i will say
for people who've been a fan of mine
since right at the beginning i think
good ones definitely touches on
some kind of themes sonic themes in
particular um that i was sort of playing
around with with my first ever
album true romance
which was very kind of 80s inspired you
know at that time i was listening to a
lot of like topow and martika and
kate bush and i've kind of found myself
there again
whilst working on this record
um so yeah i would say sonically very
much inspired by the 80s 80s pop music
and lyrically kind of inspired by
you know i feel like everybody at a
point in their life has kind of
disregarded the things that are good for
them and gone
towards the kind of danger zone you know
yeah
and so this song is really about that
it's about
running towards the fire and um you know
not really taking care of the things
that are good for you
we all have those moments in life i can
tell you that much um would you say this
track is kind of exactly where the rest
of the album will be going sonically
um
i wouldn't say exactly but yes there are
there are definitely more kind of like
80s dark moments on the record but
there's also things that aren't as dark
you know but still kind of
inspired sonically by that era so i
would say it's a pretty good reference
point yeah
um now in real life obviously you ba you
write based on your own experiences but
are you typically the one to let the
good ones go like are your friends like
charlie what are you doing
um
i think there's been there's definitely
been times where i have for sure um i'm
kind of like i would say i fall
somewhere in the middle i i feel like
sometimes i am kind of reckless and then
other times
at the opposite so but i've definitely
been guilty of that for sure
what would somebody have to have for
charlie not to let them go
oh good question um great taste in
champagne
um
high tolerance for partying
and they have to be able to make me
laugh
laughter is very important listen
talking about uh letting things go you
are an incredible songwriter and you've
written songs like same old love i don't
care just to name a few there's hundreds
out there do you have a hard time
sometimes letting those songs go to
other artists or is that just part of
being a songwriter being able to just
say okay it's yours now yeah yeah it's
kind of part of it and also it's really
fun to see
other artists sing
your songs that you've written or been a
part of writing with them you know it's
really fun to see how it kind of like
takes on a life on it of its own which
you know maybe it wouldn't have had
if i was singing it so um
it's always really good like it's always
cool to see artists put their own spin
on things that we've written together
especially when they're doing like
videos and performances like it's is
exciting
yeah for sure the video and visuals are
so important to charlie xcx as a fan
like i love always seeing a video like
this it is epic like totally epic a lot
of love went into this video um you're
dancing on your own grave in this video
which yeah you know if i was doing that
somebody in my family would be like what
are you doing you can't do this like is
there somebody in your life like that
calls you and says charlie
um
you know what i've been doing so long
now that i think my family are all just
kind of like
oh she's just
doing her thing again like you know they
get it
um and they're i'm really lucky that
they're they're all very kind of
respectful and supportive of my art and
my vision so
there's not too much pushback so that's
that's good that's always good they get
it they get it yeah
they get the charlie xcx aesthetics
speaking of our other artists i just
heard the other day that venga boys
covered 1999 which is like vega boys is
like my childhood when i was like
underage going to the clubs did you have
a chance to listen to it and what are
your thoughts on their cover of it well
troy actually texted me and was like oh
my god did you see this i was like whoa
that's crazy
um
yeah i mean it's fun for sure like and
they are kind of like
90s party starter icons so
it's very cool that um they
did that and um
yeah i you know i play the venga boys
all the time still on a night out
um because i really think that their
songs are so good and so like
you know
i don't know they just like made me want
to dance so
i'm very honored that they uh did a
cover of one of my songs
we like to party i mean they're iconic
yeah they're great
you had a hand in remixing a song for
lady gaga's chromatica album chromatica
is like something that got me through a
lot of this pandemic
uh just
you know upbeat dance music did you get
to pick which song you were remixing or
how did that work how did that whole
conversation happen with gaga
well it was interesting so actually back
in the pandemic at the peak of the
pandemic
one of her producers blood pop um kind
of hit me up and was like hey would you
want to do a remix for 9-1-1 we're
thinking about putting it out and i was
like of course yes
um and then it kind of went quiet for a
while and then you know a few months
later i was doing a q a with some fans
and they asked would you ever
collaborate or work on a gargard track
and i was like yeah of course actually i
got asked to do a remix but nothing ever
happened from it and then
the little monsters got involved they
started bombarding
the producer blood pop and then he was
like okay now we have to do it because
they're coming for me and i was like
okay yeah let's do it i would love to
but i guess just wires got crossed so
that's kind of like how it began and i
and i think then it sort of grew into
this whole like remix album um from that
but uh yeah i'm really happy that i got
to do 9-1-1 i like that song and
um
you know it was cool to like put my own
flip on it
definitely listen as like a queer man
thinking of a track like gaga and
charlie xcx would be like
is there ever gonna be something with
the two of you as a collab on the
horizon would you collab with gaga oh
yeah i mean of course i would she's
totally legendary um
and i think that she's a visionary and
has sort of paved the way for so many
younger artists and um new artists i
think
she's kind of a genius so yes for sure
like
they'll be awesome i respect her a lot
i'm just trying to manifest it here i've
got
you know like manifestation for sure you
also have a podcast called charlie xcx's
best song ever so i have to ask you
what do you think your best song ever is
and that's probably a hard question my
one that i've made
i think for me it's probably vroom vroom
just because
it's like a fan favorite whenever i play
it
the room burns down like it's so fun and
i have so many amazing memories attached
to that song so i think i'll say that
do you have a dream guest for the
podcast
dream guest i'd love to have bella porch
on the podcast i think she's really
awesome and cool so i'll say her
next year you'll be turning the big 3-0
so i have to ask are you planning a
celebration yet are we at that point
what do you want to do for your 30th
birthday if you could do anything you
know i haven't got there just yet
because i sort of only recently turned
29 but
you know i do love partying so i imagine
if everything's safe enough to do so i
will
probably throw like a rave like that is
my fave thing like to throw like a big
birthday rave so
yeah that's what i'd love
well i want to come and i want to come
in like my raves like soother you
remember this
yes
yes
um listen you were on one of my favorite
shows ever as a guest judge rupaul's
drag race it was so nice to see you on
there i do have to say a lot of your
fans online were upset with the choice
of lip sync song
i know
like very very upset the gays were upset
so i
i have to ask you if you were to go back
and choose any of your songs
to have them lip-sync to which song
would it be
well i know i've already sort of baked
it up already but i think i would pick
vroom vroom like i think that that is
like a really good lip sync song and
it's like if you crush that you are
crushing it so that would probably have
been my choice but honestly like i was
just so happy to be asked and
um i had a really good time and
honestly like watching rue do the walk
at the beginning i was dead it was
amazing
like everybody's dream to be on that
panel like
crazy
crazy um and finally listen you do have
such an incredible
queer fan base who like stan charlie xcx
i've been at the shows i've seen them
i've seen the way you've interacted with
them what do you think the uh
the reason is that so many queer people
gravitate towards your music and what
has that support meant for you
oh i mean the support that the queer
community has given me has really been
life-changing i think
they kind of like understood me when
nobody else did
um and they stood by me and that sort of
means everything to me really because i
don't think i'd be
where i am today without them um in
terms of why
uh they gravitate towards my music i
think
that you know
my art is so inherently inspired by
a lot of queer culture even when i was a
lot younger kind of growing up like
going to raves and parties in london
which were often
hosted ran by performed at by queer
people and i think you know
in in many ways queer artists who i
would meet
you know in those situations taught me a
lot about
music and parties and um
you know dancing and club nights and
like
that kind of was such a huge inspiration
on me so i think honestly maybe it's
just like
that influence is kind of like put into
my
music and like transferred through in
like kind of an organic way and
maybe that's why there's such a
connection there um but i also think
like
generally like the queer community just
has like better taste so
damn right
damn right we do
you